les accusations américaines portées
contre julian assange ont-elles un sens
washington reproche depuis le début au
lanceur d'alert d'avoir mis des vies en
danger en publiant des documents de la
diplomatie américaine
sauf que voilà une conversation
téléphonique qui remonte à 2011 entre le
fondateur de wikileaks est un avocat du
département d'état américain a fait
surface
on y apprend que le ressortissant
australien a au contraire fait preuve de
rigueur sur le fait d'expurger les
documents de leurs contenus sensibles ou
sur la protection des sources
la situation est que nous avons des
renseignements selon lesquels 250000
câbles diplomatiques des archives du
département d'état y compris les câbles
des classes et sont en train d'être ces
mines et et que nous pensons qu'ils
seront rendues publiques dans les
prochains jours et il peut y avoir une
certaine possibilité d'arrêter cette
diffusion
julian assange précise que les fuites en
question ne sont pas le fait de
wikileaks mais probablement d'un groupe
constitué autour d'un ancien employé
l'allemand daniel domscheit berg qui
avait déjà publié un ouvrage
particulièrement à charge contre julian
assange est intitulé inside wikileaks
dans les coulisses du site internet le
plus dangereux du monde
nous pensons que c'est plus votre
problème que le nôtre mais nous avons
appelé le département d'état et
l'ambassade pendant plus d'une journée
pour essayer d'expliquer l'urgence et
ils n'ont pas rappelé après cet appel un
enregistrement téléphonique authentifié
par l'actuel rédacteur en chef de
wikileaks kristinn hrafnsson et qui
démontre selon lui les accusations
portées contre julian assange
c'est une des preuves absolument
accablantes contre l'accusation
américaine dans son intégralité
il y a tant d'éléments en faveur de
julian et rappelez vous ils ont tous été
présents au cours des longues audiences
de septembre jusqu'à début octobre
cela signifie qu'il a pris grand soin
d'éviter tout préjudice et a contribué
ou a proposé de contribuer à atténuer
tous les préjudices éventuelle mais
cette proposition a été ignorée
pour edouard snowdon autres lanceurs
d'alert réfugiés pour sa part en russie
cet enregistrement est la preuve de
l'innocence de julian assange
cet enregistrement extraordinaire que je
n'avais jamais entendu auparavant
confirmé les affirmations de wikileaks
pendant des années que ces critiques ont
rejeté comme mensonge un assange a
cherché à minimiser les risques pour les
individus de la libération massive de
câbles a été forcé non intentionnelle
cette conversation téléphonique n'est
pas sans rappeler une séquence du
documentaire risque
accompagné de la journaliste britannique
sarah harrison julian assange essayaient
déjà d'alerté le secrétariat d'état
américain de la publication à venir de
ces documents sensibles non expurgés
bonjour pourrais je parlais à hillary
clinton
j'appelle du bureau de juliana sens
c'est très important
soyons clair nous n'avons pas de
problème vous en avez un
nous essayons de vous aider à résoudre
ce problème parce que nous sommes
indirectement liés à ce problème
après s'être réfugiés pendant 2400 87
jours dans l'ambassade d'équateur à
londres julian assange a par la suite
été arrêté par les autorités
britanniques
il est aujourd'hui un quart
et depuis six ans 26 jours dans la
prison de haute sécurité de belmarsh au
royaume-uni établissement qui connaît
une forte contamination qu'ovide et
malgré l'état de santé fragile du
lanceur d' alerte qui souffre notamment
d'une infection pulmonaire chronique
toutes ces demandes de libérations
conditionnelles ont été rejetés alors
même que le royaume uni a fait le choix
de libérer cette année 4000 détenus pour
éviter de nouvelles contaminations
julian assange n'est pas un criminel et
ne représente aucune menace pour
quiconque son isolement cellulaire
prolongée et qui vaut non seulement à
une détention arbitraire mais aussi à de
la torture et à d'autres peines ou
traitements cruels inhumains ou
dégradants
s'il est extradé vers les états unis
julian assange encourt une peine de 100
75 ans de prison pour espionnage
notamment une question se pose alors ces
nouvelles révélations porter aujourd'hui
à la connaissance du public sont elles
susceptibles de changer la donne pour le
lanceur d' alerte
début de réponse le 4 janvier date du
verdict de la demande d'extradition
américaine